dehors une affaire qui marche c'est
celle de beaubourg 40000 visiteurs
aujourd'hui en fin d'après midi trois
mille personnes attendaient encore de
pouvoir entrer le grand navire de verre
a réussi son lancement
c'est la ruée vers l'art pourquoi un tel
engouement pour le centre georges
pompidou entreprises après tout on dit
autant de mal que de bien
quelles sont vos impressions vous étiez
venu par curiosité sa curiosité oui mais
je trouve que le musée très bien agencé
il ya beaucoup de diversité c'est clair
seulement je ferai peut-être un petit
reproche qui a rien pour ce soir ça me
rappelle beaucoup l'aéroport de roissy
où sera une grande journée
je suis finalement se voir après le
travail
moi ça je pense que c'est tous les
restes de matériaux qui recèle aéroports
qui fut devancé curie faut que je
revienne seul d'ailleurs on était
nombreux et on n'a pas le temps de
s'arrêter pour voir maintenant sous les
voir la bibliothèque j'ai pas pu
attendre pour rentrer je pense que les
gens ont l'impression qu'il ya un lieu
ouvert à eux où ils peuvent passer leurs
loisirs dans des conditions beaucoup
plus intéressante que celle où deux des
conditions qu'ils avaient avant et je
suis persuadé que peu à peu et signeront
à l'arrêt la lecture dire la
bibliothèque est un succès considérable
nous avons des livres lus par tout le
monde la salle d'actualité rencontre un
très grand accueil à tous les degrés à
tous les nouveaux vous offrons quelque
chose aux gens qui peut leur plaît et je
crois que cette multiplicité de
possibilité qui leur est ouverte
cette possibilité dans quelques mois de
voir d'autres choses différentes de ce
que nous voyons aujourd'hui j'ai le
grand espoir que le succès de ce sens
n'est pas un feu d'artifice mais qu'il
va durer donc dès que si curiosité saine
curiosité très bonne curiosité et après
tout pourquoi ne souhaitons pas curieux